america's held hostage now behind enemy
lines and the timetable is coming fast
that's right as we are now fast
approaching america's last weekend in
afghanistan 13 of our brave soldiers are
dead they will never return home to
their families more than a dozen others
seriously wounded a total death toll is
now more than 170
over 200 people injured this is now
thousands of our own citizens our
friends our american family and yes
american allies remain trapped all
across the country all of them behind
enemy lines all of them hostage to the
whim of the terror group known as the
taliban and others and now it's harder
than ever to even get inside hamad
karzai international airport with
reports that the taliban could be in
full control of that airport now in a
matter of days some are predicting as
early as this weekend maybe the worst
part is the death and destruction and
carnage and chaos
all easily preventable so easily
preventable joe biden is defiantly
locked into his disastrous decision that
is that has rendered us a failure here
why he has tripled down on this failure
is anyone's guess why he's abiding by
the taliban's deadline also a mystery
tonight why he's not sending in
additional troops to rescue every single
solitary
american behind enemy lines is
unforgivable why he's so accepting of
the idea that americans will be left
behind is beyond anything that any good
american that i know of can comprehend
and sadly tonight that outcome seems
inevitable this was not an intelligence
community failure joe biden ignored what
are dozens and dozens of warnings on the
ground and they've been given to him now
for months our source is confirming he
ignored his own military advisors that
too has been ongoing for months he
ignored the intel community he ignored
the taliban's clear you can see the map
with the time frame their rapid advance
from april to june to july to august and
everywhere in between and yesterday well
what do we see you know incoherent
mumbling bumbling rambling press
conference showing the entire world
america's friends and allies and yeah
hostile regimes and our foes our enemies
alike that the united states of america
has a cognitively weak frail and
completely out of touch president that
is clinging to failed policies this is
beyond a national embarrassment innocent
people will likely die as a result of
all of this more will die so
congratulations joe this is your mission
accomplished now at least 13 american
families will never be the same many
more brave servicemen will struggle with
serious injuries for the rest of their
lives and more than 100 other innocent
civilians have perished but when you
think things couldn't get worse well you
think again because today in a statement
at 1 pm eastern time earlier today
gensake warning that another terror
attack in kabul is likely there will be
another terror attack and there's
nothing that we apparently can do
this is a nightmare a failure of epic
proportions the worst foreign policy
disasters one of in our nation's history
with deadly real-life consequences and
risks that remain higher than ever
remember just last week biden said any
attack on our forces or disruption of
our operations at karzai international
airport will be met with swift and
forceful response well now that swift
and forceful response is nowhere to be
found just like so many other biden
promises those words appear to be
totally completely hollow
seemingly like what's in his head at
most hours of the day
when the president says we will hunt you
down and make you pay
what does that look like is he going to
order a mission to kill the people
responsible or would he be satisfied if
they are captured and brought to trial
i think he made clear yesterday that he
does not want them to live on the earth
anymore
in other words there is no plan of
action other than a stern talking to
even obama's defense secretary even
former cia director he did both jobs
leon panetta he rightly is calling for a
swift military response i don't agree
with him politically but he knows what
he's talking about here of course this
morning joe biden himself could not be
bothered to answer any other questions
about afghanistan especially after and
in light of yesterday's disaster not
even they told me to call on
whoever being dictated by his staff he
doesn't want them to get mad at him
obviously they call the shots take a
look
i met with my commanders this morning
first thing in the morning got a
detailed briefing
about yesterday's attacks and the
measure they're taking to protect our
forces and complete the mission
and we will complete the mission now i'm
not going to take any questions
because of the
prime minister being here on
afghanistan now but i'll be available at
another time
i'm not going to take questions i might
get yelled at again what will happen to
americans
clearly now it seems inevitable we will
be leaving them behind
how will they ever get out
what are we doing to protect them
what will happen to karzai international
airport in kabul when we do pull out
what will joe do if more americans are
murdered like yesterday what will he do
if the taliban
murders an afghan with one of our
special immigrant visa the ones we made
a pledge to if it ever came to this we
would get you the hell out of there but
we didn't keep our word to them many
will die
and joe gave him a list of names so they
now have a database biometrics and joe's
list they're being hunted down as we
speak they will be
executed one after another
how do many americans we still don't get
an answer are still in afghanistan how
many americans have been evacuated they
don't know
how will he prevent the rise of isis or
al qaeda with no embassy no intel
presence on the ground you know they
were at war with us we weren't at war
with them that 9 11 commission report
yeah all the plotting and planning and
scheming that took place inside of
afghanistan in the lead up to 9 11 2001
20 years ago
what will happen to the 83 billion
dollars that joe biden the weapons that
he left behind the most powerful
weaponry of any military force on the
face of the earth now he gave it to
terrorists
and is there any plan to secure it's a
little too late because now we have
images of taliban flying
our blackhawk attack helicopters or
riding around in our armored vehicles
208 helicopters and aircraft he left
behind how does biden plan to vet what
is now tens of thousands of afghan
refugees because as we speak
there are so many refugees flying into
washington dc
apparently they're doing the vetting
after people are in the air flying to
this country it's causing a massive
bottleneck at dulles international
airport we need to know how these
individuals are being vetted reports
that already over a hundred people that
have come to america from afghanistan
are also on our terrorist watch list
clearly there are a lot of important
questions that need to be answered and
joe biden his incoherent mumbling and
bumbling and unwillingness and inability
to answer them is chilling
yesterday during a bizarre
you know one of his
bizarre moments at that press conference
joe biden was completely dazed and
confused with an image
that went viral take a look
terrorists
attacked
that we've been talking about and
worried about
that the intelligence community
has assessed has undertaken
an attack by a group known as isis k
and gave me a list here
the first person i was instructed to
call on was
kelly o'donnell of nbc getting every
single person out
is
can't be guaranteed by anybody because
there's a determination all who wants to
get out as well no no no wait a minute
i'm asking you a question is that
accurate the best year or not
because look at it this way folks and
i'm gonna i have another meaning for
real
i know it's not fair to ask you
questions this is rhetorical but raise
your hand if you think we should have
gone
this image
of an american president
is why i've been saying somebody so weak
and frail
and such a cognitive mess
america deserves better
we don't leave our fellow citizens our
fellow americans behind
we rescue our fellow americans trapped
behind enemy lines we respond to terror
attacks with overwhelming force we have
the greatest military on the face of the
earth we strike fear into the hearts of
all of our enemies and instill
confidence in all of our allies
but under biden
none of that has happened and clearly
will happen made that clear yesterday
the one thing that was clear no more
military presence we're getting out
we're sticking to the timetable and yeah
there'll be americans left behind in all
likelihood now we're suffering the
consequences of his real weaknesses in
real time mark my words with so many
trap this could all get so much worse
before it gets better and i pray that i
am wrong hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else